It's going fast
First challenge in a very very long time
Playing while hula-hooping
This is the perfect first challenge
because it gets you warmed up
Get your hips moving
The footwork makes it a bit..
some footwork
I have to move
little by little
Oh, I know!
Give me to the middle
Okay Otto
That's the way to do it
Did it go on!?
Easy shot!
How did that go on?
This must be one of the most stupid looking things we've done
I got it!
I found the way
So many ways you can do this
It's going fast
Let's do a few around the nets
Dynamite!
Sideways table
Didn't expect this to be this hard
Yeah same
Well, we got five
We got five
Let's try some juggling
I can't even see anything
I just need to focus on the balls
One!
Come on come on, keep going!
Okay, we can get three
It came on
I got a point
Good enough
So we have just launched our own racket
and racket case
These are some really cool products
Go and check them out from pongfinity.store
You learn something new every day
I can put that on my CV